now in australia the military is now
patrolling the streets to enforce the
lockdown
about 300 troops have been sent to
australia's largest city
to help overstretch police monitor home
quarantine for coronavirus patients and
potentially set up roadblocks the troops
will help the police
on a door-to-door search to check if
people
who've contracted covet are isolating
dystopian you bet in germany they're now
banned from even protesting coveted
dictates
but thousands still showed up in berlin
to voice their anger anyway
here's how they were met after
participants did not heed orders to
abide by hygiene rules mask and social
distancing police used pepper spray
and truncheons to break up the crowd
600 were arrested sounds like china
in hong kong here now is mike pompeo
former secretary of state
and fox news contributor mr secretary
great to see you tonight
um this is terrifying
to me personally but you do get the
sense that
there are some democrats who wish
this this was playing out the same exact
way in the united
states well thanks for having me on it
would be an enormous mistake to try
anything that was remotely like what you
just described what was happening there
in germany
to go to the lockdowns that are
happening in other countries across the
world would make no sense for the united
states there's
scant evidence that these kind of
lockdowns do a whole lot of good
and we know they do an enormous amount
of damage to the economy to the mental
health of the people that live there
it saddens me when i see democrat
governors and even democrats in
washington d.c
who want to head down that path they
want to go back to lockdowns back to the
kind of things that
we we tried right it was 15 days to stop
the spread
the the right answer was to give people
good information
sound information truthful information
let them make the own their own
decisions for themselves
and then the work that our
administration did to develop warp speed
and these vaccines also has delivered
good outcomes all across the world mr
secretary these are our allies
our vaunted allies and these are
i mean biden is lavishing praise on them
for how
he's working with them they have a great
new relationship
uh this looks like china in hong kong
laura everything about the bite
administration
administration's
demonstrated that it wants to look more
like europe right once that bigger
government spend more money
have people work less uh european
socialism is the model that the byte
administration has adopted
that they've gotten in bed with them on
iran they've done the same with respect
to climate change
you're right i i suspect with respect to
how they're approaching
how to respond to this virus they're
thinking about things the same way it's
not about freedom
it's not about the american tradition
it's not about the things we know best
about how to make sure people have the
information they need to stay stable
stay unhealthy
mr secretary at the same time we have uh
biden promising that we're going to get
europe to work with us
against china and yet even nbc
is saying the u.s struggles to unite the
democratic european union
allies against china it's just not
it's not happening so they're just
ignoring biden all together and cutting
their own deals with china
what does that do to u.s national
security
yeah it's really dangerous we began the
effort to convince the europeans that it
was time to get serious with respect to
responding to the chinese communist
party
we'd begun to make progress we made real
progress in getting them to kick huawei
out of their country right
telecommunications systems that we're
going to spread not only their
information but american information
into the chinese system
now the administration hasn't yet been
able to convince the europeans certainly
the big two france and germany
to work alongside of us but i think
there's real opportunity besides those
two countries there are many european
countries who i do think
understand this threat from china in the
same way that you and i do
and i hope the bite administration can
rally them and those two large economies
to say that the west must stand together
against the tyrion and communism that
are emanating from china today yeah but
the problem is there's no there's no
price to be paid from biden he's not
gonna
he's gonna end up doing anything to them
they're just gonna keep rolling forward
cutting their own
deals that's the concern but speaking of
china mr secretary just moments ago
bill gates was on cnn and he was asked
about the investigations
into the origins of covet
how important do you think it is to
understand how this happened how it
started
i mean is that critical in terms of
preventing in the future
no the source isn't going to change you
know the need for masks and vaccines and
the need to have a
a very different regimen so that uh
you know all countries could get on top
of the cases
very quickly and be more like australia
than europe or the united states
so mr secretary it's not vital that we
find out what happened to prevent the
next
pandemic wow that that's really
something
i i must say it's absolutely essential
that we understand how this virus
escaped where it escaped from
but remember too lord that lab that the
lab that i believe this virus came from
is still operating it's still conducting
research on viruses
that the military and their biological
experts are still working there
that this could happen again tomorrow or
the next day it's absolutely imperative
that we understand how the chinese
communist party foisted this virus upon
the world
to say otherwise is well frankly it's at
best naive
yes or no are you in favor of biden's
about to be announced policy that
foreigners visiting the united states
have to show vaccination status no
makes no sense there are much better
ways to protect the american people than
to
begin to have international standards
for who can come in showing some kind of
card it does it doesn't make sense it's
unlikely to actually work for the
american people
secretary pompeo great to see you thank
you so much hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else